what's up guys I'm back I'm going to
show you guys a money-making video you
can do with doing fletching it's pretty
FK and it's super easy so you need 63
fletching ruby tipped adamant bolt and
so what happened I'll show you guys my
history so I was trying to find a cheap
price for the ruby bolt kit but the
prices weren't really what I was liking
so I decided you know what I'm going to
buy some rubies and cut them myself so I
went ahead and bought 90 rubies for 1200
coins each and then but a thousand out
of my bolt tips and so I'm going to put
these in here and so all you need to cut
the rubies is six three fletching and
such is also used on it and make all
them and so all so here and all time how
long it takes to do one full inventory
and then I'll get back to you guys smell
right on back so it took about a minute
and 16 seconds so we'll just say a
minute and I'll go ahead and try to sell
one from the a meter I did okay so yeah
right here okay so I saw one let's see
okay so it instant sold for 188 okay so
now let's do the math and make it as if
redoing this out early so we'll do the
118 that we sold it for and we'll times
that by the 324 of them total so that
gives us thirty eight thousand two
hundred thirty-two so I'll write that
down and then we'll do the twelve
hundred that it costs to buy each Ruby
times the twenty seven that we did in
our inventory
so thirty two thousand four hundred -
advanced cool - back from the other
number so thirty-eight thousand two
hundred 32 - 34 32 400 so 5832 so we'll
times up by 60 minutes so 350 K and if
it's a good margin then you'll make
about 400 K and an hour just sitting
here so now I'll cut the rest of them
and I'll go ahead and time it and tell
you guys how long it takes to cut the
rest of the 90 ruies
so it took about three and a half
minutes to cut the rest of the 90 and
add that with some minute it took to cut
the single inventory it's about four and
a half minutes I'll write that down and
now get in time how long it takes to use
the Ruby bolt it's on the Ottoman Bowl
clips and we'll see how long it takes
all right so I'm almost done and as you
can see in the top right corner 150 mm
XP per hour doing this so about 150,000
fletching experience per hour
a few wrecks with last time 361 each so
I'll go ahead and put them in for 361
and I'll sound alright so when they're
sell I'll come back alright so they
didn't sell for 361 so I went ahead and
put them in for 360 so 386 PK will do
that real quick we'll do those 360
thousand whoops 360,000 - the 228,000 it
costs to buy the adamant bolts and then
we'll - the 108 thousand it cost to buy
the rulli's so 24,000 so I want to take
3 minutes ok so it took 3 minutes to do
all that
so we'll do sixty divided by three 20s
we'll do the 20 times for 24,000
about 500k so you can make about 500k an
hour doing this and that's just sitting
here basically afk alright thanks guys
for watching stay tuned from the next
video